to me you've got to understand that deer
are now is worth more than oil and so
they're gonna put a lot of money into
the secure in that and we're gonna put a
lot of money in the defendant
now I'm genuinely proud of living in
England and in Britain because we have
some of the best security professionals
in the world but you have a lot of
threat actors as well so you've got
China
you've got Russia you've got North Korea
you've got all the states that wouldn't
necessarily get on with us politically
and you have to understand that for the
price of one fighter plane you can hire
200 hackers so information warfare is
going to be the future of war I am
joined by Tom Johnson ethical hacker and
social engineer extraordinaire
welcome to the show Tom it's great to
have you on it's gonna be an exciting
one today this world of ethical hacking
and social engineering is something that
I've seen a little bit about online but
I don't really know all that much but I
guess we're gonna we're gonna delve into
it today right let's find out how do you
define ethical hacking and social
engineering and what you do and then and
then let's find about out about the the
Genesis story absolutely ok so social
engineer a guy called Christopher
harmony in America is the art of using
human psychology or misusing human
psychology to get a target to do
something or say something they
shouldn't do or say and now these
grassroots so if you can talk someone
into giving you the passwords or
plugging in USB stick into the computer
then all of this very expensive so the
cyber security mitigation is useless
because they are literally giving you
the keys to the kingdom so that is what
it is I understand yeah I suppose as
these technological firewalls and safety
measures become more sophisticated the
ways around it
that don't require you to just
brute-force try and break through
something that's heavily encrypted
I guess this sort of falls to the the
one remaining weak link in the chain
which is always going to be the the
several million year old brain that sits
inside of the person controlling the
system right well in my opinion humans
can be the weakest link but they can
also be the strongest link as well
because they think in a different way to
how computers process information so if
you ever had a good feeling before
Christian yeah
well I'm good feeling is your
subconscious mind telling you that there
is something not quite right in a
pattern so your subconscious mind is
constantly processing everything around
you and then when you get that good
feeling that is your subconscious mind
seeing your conscious mind is something
not quite right here so that is a really
good way to defend against social
engineers that good feeling got you okay
so let's start off the genesis story how
do you say what happens whereby you are
now sat opposite me with a microphone in
front of you talking about ethical
hacking and social engineering where
does it begin
right it begins when I was about 12
years old and I was pulled out of school
by an overprotective mother and I was a
very small child in a predominantly
council area in Wallsend and and it
wasn't a very good time at school for me
and she was very overprotective pulled
me out and had nothing to give me
workwise so she just sucked me in front
of a computer so I started playing games
what every child tends to do and then I
started getting bored a games and I
couldn't afford new games so I started
working out how I could break the system
and copy those games so I could get them
for free not because I was a criminal
but because I wanted to play games the
game started getting boring so I wanted
to learn how the games work so I
programmed the games and things
developed on and on and on and then
something amazing happened this
rudimentary thing called the Internet
come about and it become my playground
and I was spending all of my time online
I had no moral or ethical compass at
that point in time I was young
I wasn't a bad lad but I've done things
because I was a bit mischievous so I
would have random computers on the
internet and download through all that
look through all the files and then it
started getting boring so I started
going a bit further I started college I
got thrown out to college for hacking an
internal mail system
I was yeah it was naughty but I was
sending messages from one lecturer to
another seeing that there were in love
with each other there are all sorts of
different things body looks I was great
at doing things were terrible often
thrown oh dear College so I went back
again I lasted about two weeks and I was
thrown out again and I lost the network
manager of his computer and he didn't
say funny site so you've got to
understand that the same time me skills
were developing and to a point where
college wasn't really teaching me
anything so it was a bit bored if that
makes sense so it just sort of
encouraged me to do more and more risky
things silly things when I look back on
the white hat now may I just add that a
white hat is somebody who puts ethics
over morals over everything solo or Nia
within the boundaries of law but in
those days anything online was fair game
and I was willing to be mothers for
envelope because of course it was on
dialogue at the time she used to put a
little and Kate cord on so I wrote a
little program that would go through
every single key code and and brute
force it and then one day I heard a
knock at the door and sat on there was
two big burly police officers standing
in front of us the subsequently arrested
me took me to the police station locked
me up for about 15 hours threatened to
extradite me to America where and get
death by lethal injection and everything
and I was absolutely terrified
however I was about 16 17 ish hit the
bed at a young age to be having such
heavy words
everything area and 20 years later I
found out it was a social engineer an
attack on us it was actually two of my
mother's friends who were Papa's who she
put them up to the task of scarily
Street so it wasn't the real arrest no
good enough for below so that was my
first taste of social engineering and
believe you me was very effective so
then I did that's gay straight it scared
me straight for a very long time in fact
I lost me love of computers for a while
I took it hoop line and sinker and I was
genuinely in fear of my life and I just
stayed away from complete as a set of a
company I don't know all right out of
the company and then that went under and
I just thought to meself what do I wanna
do do I want to earn minimum wage for
the rest of my life so look at the skill
set that I had and I thought I want to
go back into the cyber security now it
is a job it wasn't Batman it was a crime
but now it's a job so I had no
qualifications to be named so I blanked
me with a site University course they
give me a shot and I've received it at
first with honors in every module so far
so I've done all right
amazing that's fantastic so that's
that's the journey that you've taken
yourself on there so how do you go from
the online to the offline is it off
offline hacking right yeah well it's
more in personally it's like it's like
the good old-fashioned con that's
exactly what it is but it's got a cyber
element to it okay so if you remember
the old con men or con women who would
trick you into insulting that is exactly
what social engineering can be it's
tricking somebody into doing something
saying something you shouldn't so a set
of a little company I started doing a
little bit of work with the police
little bits and bobs here and there and
then I don't need to talk outside but
that's you know it's it's a
north-northeast convention northeast of
England and then I was in
from that talk to do a talk at the local
government level now the talk that a
dorm was based upon a hack that I
carried out an ethical hack on the
university never studied that so I was a
first year student bearing in mind when
this took place and that approach the
school of computing can I test your
security please and they said yes twelve
years old did they just think that it
was some sub student who didn't really
know what he was doing didn't realize
they were coming up against boss level
55 hacking skills 24 hours worked out
how their smart card system worked and I
built a corner that could clone the
cards so I then dressed there was a
security guard and mrs. the social
engineer and side of things put the hive
is on can we superman changed she have
me head looked completely different and
then went round and skimmed all of the
staffs cards and with those cards i had
access to all areas free parking for six
weeks period free food
library books everything you could ever
want was all there free i didn't tell
Teesside University until cyberfest
which was a little bit naughty and then
I saw the give away all the secrets and
it got a little bit of attention
meditate yeah it did but then I've got
invited to the ICD DF the information
communication data in digital forensics
convention which is Europe's largest
cause cybersecurity convention for
police law enforcement and military so I
was invited by the national police
chief's council to do a talk there real
and the center of this sort of stuff
then absolutely absolutely it's about as
big as you can get it was in the night
only you know you couldn't get through
the doors and I still invited so I
arrived
expected to be shot in a little side
room just doing a little filler talk and
I was doing the big company suite and
there was a keynote speaker so it was
absolutely terrifying so I talk in front
of 600 of sort of the world's best
professionals on cybersecurity and
especially social engineering hit the
bed absolute you wanna see what I got is
rather got that what's that that's a
plaque certificate of appreciation
that's so cool
that's from these up from the home
office that's from the home office yeah
[Music]
there it is drop it this is even cooler
this is an honor cone that I was given
believe it or not off the home office
okay the FBI oh that's an AT&T and TAC
what what does what does that mean and
what is it it's like a big plastic
plastic coin so this is what you call it
on a coin and it's what I was awarded
for doing the talk so that's the site
there that's the important one that's
the national police chief's council our
central government and the National
Crime Agency and on that side we've got
AT&T you sponsored the event for you
we've got the Metropolitan Police
the British government that little rung
on there is the FBI operational
technological division [ __ ] me it has
big names on this thing yeah and the
bottom one is the National Technical
Assistance Center for to me my value
possession of went wrong port scanning
the FBI when I was a kid yeah
so now sort of working alongside them it
was really exciting unbelievable so off
the back of this talk that you've given
presumably it's it's been interesting to
a quite a few people in the audience
what happens from there D is there any
job offers do you get any emails is
anyone
getting a fair few job offers all the
time to be to be fair but I'm currently
putting them on hold I went on another
journey now which is the technical side
I'm currently studying her osep which is
offensive security certified
professional actor
I should receive that in two months and
then the world is my oyster what's the
most recent qualification what does that
mean that is we have an operating system
I mean you see it just behind me here
that's a Kali Linux which is not a
windows-based system it's a it's a
Debian based system and offensive
security to meet Kali Linux have an
accreditation called OS CP and it's
called pwk penetration with Kali Linux
so once I get that it's a globally
recognized certification okay and that
is like you said the technical side so
is it rare to find hackers who have the
in-person skills alongside the technical
know-how or define DFAC do you find
people who have that mindset with
regards to just trying to open doors
whether it's online or offline they're
just interested either way I think you
have more technological than you have
social engineers sorry Leslie free is
that you have more good technical
hackers than you have good social
engineers so every every hacker has the
potential to attempt social engineering
techniques and tactics but some are
better than others and it's relatively
rare to find a nerd like myself with the
ability to be able to talk to people as
well
so I take pleasure in teaching and
communicating and in helping
organizations and that in itself helps
me sort of sharpen me social engineer
and toolset I've recently done a hack on
it on a large unnamed company an ethical
hacker I was employed to test their
security um
and part of my training them allowed me
to advance my social engineering and
I'll explain now
I was I was approached by this company
and asked if I could test their human
firewall so I spent three about three
weeks
exfiltrated information doing
reconnaissance on the passive and active
finding out who the staff were who were
talking to troll doll of the Facebook's
the LinkedIn all of the social media
about the profiles on them a prioritized
five staff who I thought would be the
weakest and approached them over
LinkedIn for my pretext which was my lie
so I tried multiple I don't know whoever
betrayed secrets but I tried multiple
lies and a couple of them was successful
that I managed to hook a couple of them
but one a prioritized I went in a held a
meeting with them pertaining assault and
that didn't exist and then left and in
that short amount of time I had already
cloned all of the cards together at the
building 50 minutes of my actual
exploitation phase I was in their inner
sanctum through multiple corridors
drinking cups of coffee in their tea
station for three and a half hours
unquestioned it was it was good it was
interesting was exciting is that what
you call a successful hack yes to be
totally honest with you that were very
good on a lot of areas but they just
didn't expect an attack of that
magnitude to take place so the final
straw was I was asking stuff to step
away from the computer so I was plugging
in covert hacking tools like the USB
rubber ducky and the bash pony which
look like USB devices but on the tell us
about those I want to know what those do
right well USB Roberto he was created by
a company called hack 5 shout out
Shannon Morse and Aaron kitchen and they
created a device called an hid human
if this device now it looks to the
computer like it's a keyboard with
somebody typing on the other end but it
can take thousands of current as a
minute so I could spend a full dear
according exploits to compromise their
systems and then I'll pull this device
in and it types it out locally system
yes okay
yeah so it thinks it's a person typing
and the bash pony is an attack a multi
attack platform which can emulate
Ethernet over USB which is trusted by
Windows iOS and Linux and you can run
peel or steal password hashes do all
sorts with it even through a locks net
yes serious stuff oh come on I want to
find out what are the other what's the
other like atomic weapons or what if we
were to open up the ethical hackers
toolkit or the bag what have you got
inside of you've got the rubber ducky
we've got little single board computers
raspberry PI's really useful they'll run
off a battery and I've got Wi-Fi
Bluetooth and that's a full PC there but
they do get small you can get a little
raspy by zeroes which are absolutely not
much bigger than the size of a matchbox
but it's essentially a computer in your
in your pocket pretty much but we get
even smaller and that's 100 PC there
that is one which is probably the size
of just bigger than a lighter but
totally two-dimensional well there's the
USB stick
yep but it's just a bit bigger than a
USB stick yeah standard USB sticks with
malicious software on them and you can
you can generate malware and then you
can use a crypt I like veil evasion too
muskets final signature so the antivirus
systems don't pick up on it okay so the
very system that you used to protect you
works against you because it doesn't
flag you have any problems any and you
think that you're safe as well so you're
probably
solutely probably a little bit more
complacent about the security that you
should have in place oh well even if
someone does get through the antivirus
will catch it yeah absolutely so I've
got a normal line that gp6 Quinn got may
be really useful it's got a little
covert camera in the bottom of it no
unlisted comes off and it's a USB stick
really hardly leave them in cigarette
areas and stop them to record staff and
then exfiltrated information from that
we've got this device it's held together
with tear because I use it quite a bit
but this is a scary scary device okay it
looks to me just like a motherboard
encased in a plastic shell it does but
it isn't I'll explain what it is it's
actually I'll give you two two
definitions one the tech definition and
to the everyday English definition so
this is the software-defined radio
transceiver operating from one megahertz
to 6 gigahertz and in English it's a
radio transmitter and receiver that
talks the technology but you can talk to
Bluetooth with it you can talk to Wi-Fi
you can talk to NFC you can talk to the
little readers on the doors that allows
you in the buildings you can talk to GPS
with it you can literally with this
device snatch telephone calls out of the
air decrypt the conversation yeah so and
what so how does that does that need to
be powered is it battery power how does
that work use plug it into your USB port
in your computer and that powers it does
eat the battery quite a bit it's quite
sort of power hungry yeah depending on
which frequencies you're operating on if
you're operating on low frequency
there's less priam so it's less
the operator and high-frequency it's
obvious workers more daring so it has to
use more power to do that so you need to
be that particular device that you've
just brought up there does that need to
be in the facility about 100 yards away
okay so you can depend on what you're
talking to if it's low-frequency as
opposed to high views it depends on what
you're talking to if it's if it's a door
lock you need to be relatively close to
the system gonna say I'll just park the
car outside and start doing stuff with
her well criminals use those very tools
to steal cars so the sitting as the car
park and they're running a slipper and
they literally capture the the chords of
the car keys the older cars works with
what you call the Reaper they attack so
you literally just capture the door lock
court and then replay it through the
device and the doors on the cars will
open but do you have you seen all the
modern cars like he's getting stolen
with the people who stand outside to the
houses with the antennas look for the
keys so I've seen a blog post about it
but if you understand Tommy it'd be
great for you to tell the listeners
because it's a really cool story
well it's called we really attack sorry
not a replay attack a relay attack so
what the do is the pretty much sit the
device in between the car and the key in
the house and what they do is the scan
with an antenna - how how it works is
the car sends what we call the weigand
signal which powers up the key so when
you come in repeat like get in range of
the car it powers up the key the key
responds the car knows you knows that
that's the correct key so you sit there
and you're relieved from the car to the
key the key to the car and then the car
opens and then the drive off with it so
that's how it works I'm not going to
tell you how sorry I am I saw this blog
post I think it might even been on Top
Gear or something like that and they
were talking about some of these really
new fairly hot like a Ford cougar or
something else like a pretty new 19 play
cars that were being stolen in under 30
seconds
by using this sort of this sort of
approach
terrified absolutely
that car is is fighting the signal power
of black King if that keys out arrange
the cars locked as soon as that key goes
into range even in or in Albans bought
the SDS they are the software-defined
radio is extending that range like like
a relay and runner yeah there's a
passive map button that signal backwards
and forwards so the car knows no
difference
so for anyone that's listening if you've
got a vehicle which has got keyless
entry and engine start how can they
protect themselves that's the question
[Music]
it's like the Faraday cage it stops the
signal getting out you can buy a little
wallets for the keys manufacturers are
now looking at creating keys that
disable themselves unless they actually
move so when you move them and wobble
them they'll reactivate themselves but
it's just a matter of time before the
black hats and the cyber criminals come
up with ways around that you know yeah
clever stuff really really clever stuff
yeah that's really interesting so we've
got the the rubber ducky we've got the
Bosch bunny we've got the at that
Wireless the camera that's inside of a
lighter is unbelievable literally just
looks like a lighter and it's got a
camera on the bottom of it we've got you
your relay forgetting stuff from the
facility and sending that back in what
else have you got or what else would you
want to use if you were if you're
needing to get a hack and maybe stuff
blank cards and stuff like that I guess
for replacing blank cards for using on
access from good old China for about 25
pence each you want I use simple things
like cameras really cheap buy them off
eBay
just shut the day if you should and then
you can capture people it's all good for
listening to conversation at a later
date so things you may have missed it
might just be that one tiny little bit
of information that you can use to
leverage that person or that company I
mean I've tried everything
tried bribery go up to somebody
look let me into the building are you
200 quid you try everything within scope
so you have a document of scope set up
by the company and they literally see
what you can and what you can't do and
then you just try and leverage the
information that you pull down but we do
all sorts of things like we check to see
females have been involved in data
breaches so if you register with a
website and then that web site gets
hacked and your details get leaked then
we can check to see those emails have
been involved in data breaches and which
data breaches have been involved in yeah
I mean for a for a cyber criminal it
would take a minute and a half to
download the entire Twitter ID at a base
in plain text if you know what I the
look it's there and that's so LinkedIn
had a data breach not so long ago and a
bunch of a bunch of logins account
information was taken from that mine is
one of them one thing that I didn't do
all I have done now with a updated
password protected shout out to one
password Thiago Forte's suggestion to me
which has been an absolute lifesaver I
had the same password for LinkedIn as my
deliverer Roo yeah so I've got a mess
woke up one morning for a message of my
business partner and he said is this you
or during Nando's in London on my card
because his card was on my account I
must have ordered summer for him so I
was like oh he did then did make sure
that I was billed for it on the company
account but yeah and sure enough it
they'd used my details and they must
have just brute force checked a whole
bunch of other platforms to see does
this email and password combination
appear on this this is this is this and
sure enough on delivery it did and 45
Nando's later that
add it away that's social engineering
101 the human psychology me the way that
your Wiegand makes it difficult to
remember complex random passwords so
what we do is we create something that
we know most passwords have a capital
first letter and have numbers at the end
why because through school were taught
to capitalize the first letter of a
sentence so when we're generating our
password we capitalize the first letter
because we know it means a capital we'll
put the number at the end because it's
at the end and we'll remember it it's
not only two digits or four digits and
date of birth or a memorable date also
and simple like 1 2 3 or at the end of
the password passwords are normally
constructed out if you English English
words which can be found in a dictionary
and it doesn't take very long to crack a
password the entire character set of 8
characters including uppercase lowercase
numbers and special characters in its
entirety can be cracked in two hours now
so if you're looking at longer passwords
if it's constructed of English words and
numbers and letters we use dictionary
attacks so we'll say ok we'll try
dictionary 1 in dictionary term and
we'll use a rule set the capitalized the
first letters or not and put numbers at
the end from 1 in 3,000 and then that
reduces that current asset down
massively so you can you can crack a lot
of passwords relatively quickly
is that brute-force stuff there where
you just start you'll set some sort of
program away and it will just start
cycling through version 1 version 2
version 3 version 4 no brute force isn't
very efficient the air current ascent
which I said can be cracked in its
entirety that is a brute-force attack
yes as you start getting the 910 its
inconceivably long yeah so what you do
is you use rule sets and dictionaries so
it's not a brute force you're not going
through like 0 0 0 0 is 0 0 you
literally combining different words
together and using sort of different
numbers and rule sets alongside it but a
lot of people use a it's called a Koresh
it's where you substitute a letter for a
number so I becomes one or becomes zero
he becomes three a lot of people use
that in the passwords because it's
easier to remember but that's the first
thing somebody's gonna try they're going
to use a reset to try that so now we've
got what you call GPU hacking sorry
cracking we use something called hash
tag and you can put together graphics
cards in a number of graphics cards
which are very very good at mathematics
so the much much quicker than stately
you crackin so it's just you know it's
it's getting much much tougher now I can
give you a really good hint one pass
things like passwords saves the all good
and well unless somebody gets you master
password and then they've got all the
keys to the kingdom so you can create
something called pneumonic password
generation ahead of that yeah
so you think of a sentence specific to
you
for example Tommy it's 27 pies and now
he is fat yes which is not very good and
then you take the first letter and all
the special characters from the south
first letter of each word in all the
special characters are numbers in it
generates a password so in our minds we
can remember the sentence because we've
evolved over millions of years language
but on paper it looks like a very long
string of random numbers letters and
special characters and it's super sad
you are okay that's interesting yeah I
am it's terrifying to know that every
different permutation of eight
characters of a character special
characters letters etc can be run
through in the space of two hours that's
I mean that that is really really
concerning so I guess you know first off
yes that's under a hundred days and I
think most websites now just dictate
that it needs to be a minimum of eight
characters one uppercase and sometimes
once
your character so I'm gonna get most
people will take the path of least
resistance and choose exactly eight
characters exactly one special character
exactly one number as well most people
do yeah I am I saw a what's it called a
word storm where the most common words
are the biggest and the most common
password apparently across the entire
Internet is password one capital P the
password password one with a capital P
and I've just guessed it and I haven't
got I'm you know Thomas of different
species to me when it comes to tracking
but I've just guessed your password but
for the love of God please go and change
it from password one with a capital P
new password and I would not use English
words I would put a little bit of slang
in there or I would change it about if
you're not going to pneumonic ly
generate a password try and me it is
random and not likely to be in a
dictionary as possible
got you okay well that's that's some
good takeaways already for today so keep
you your keyless entry car keys inside
of a Werther's Originals like tin and
make sure that you've got a twelve
twelve digits password which isn't isn't
pure English so getting back to the
ethical hacking and the social
engineering and stuff like that have you
got some some cool stories some
experiences that you've been through
recently that you think some of the
listeners might be interested to hear
yeah I mean we can continue we can
explain certain things pertaining to
that so initially we set up this meeting
created a product or a project that
didn't exist and I talked about it for
an hour I don't know how I did it just
all floored out but when I first arrived
there I still used the loom and that was
because I was given a visitor's pass and
the first thing I wanted to do was use
me more by afford to take photographs of
that Pass mobile phones now we've got a
resolution high enough to pretty much
print out the pass and me
relatively realistic I notice that the
land yacht was a generic Lenya that you
could buy of ebay by 20 different colors
for like deer tena and I had the lord of
them in the back of my car so after the
meeting I went home I produced a new
pass the lanyard on in the next day I
went in a way to tell the swapped for
lunch the people on the desk and I just
walked straight past used to clone card
that I had access to the room was
drinking cups of coffee for a while one
of the stories within that is there was
somebody fought a copy on a photocopier
and I started getting so bored of just
sitting there I walked up to and
pretended I was from the photocopying
company misalliance Tom from the
photocopying company how is your machine
behaving today I've been told it's been
a little bit naughty lately and she said
yeah yeah last week it was a bit bad but
now it's working fine and I said cool
excellent it's just like a courtesy call
would you mind showing me the other for
the copier in your mini building which
was like yeah sure had no problem
you know why do you think I wanted to
show me I knew where it was okay to get
access through the different doors maybe
to where it was in the building
no it was on the same floor do I do you
think try and think I think you owe me
this Elliot tell me come on it was
because I wanted to be seen being
associated with that member of stuff so
when she's walking across the floor with
me I was really loud I was talking I was
talking I was having a laugh
and people were looking look at that
loud man over there he's with Shirley or
whatever her name was
and that means within their mind I'm
meant to be there does that make sense
absolutely yeah this is a reputation by
association type thing absolutely
absolutely so a little bit later on
actually not questioned offer of a guy
who was quite an sort of security aware
many Columbo is like up
have you what today mommy oh yeah my
name's Tom or where do you work I said I
work in IT how long have you worked here
fights a lovely building he said I
suddenly switched the conversation over
to him well people love talking about
themselves they spend about fifteen
minutes telling us about he worked there
for 15 years he was telling us all about
his wife and his children and everything
and he completely forgot about question
and who I was in all that time I was
recording on me foreign meetings between
people exfiltrated information that way
I was planting devices like this a
little remote transmitter bug in
Thailand a way to start a mobile phone
then you can listen to things going on
in meeting rooms and things like that
this even installed one of these in one
of the rooms yeah yeah
it's a cheapy little covert camera but
it transmits so you can transmit a video
feed okay what what I've done is a lot a
little facial recognition system in
Python um what it what I do is I scrape
the website for pictures of the
employees and then pop them into my
little facial recognition system in the
link it with a little bit of information
about them that I've already searched
and I wear a cap with a camera in it
yeah and I wear one of one of these
which is a little covert headset and
that bit there goes underneath your
shirt and those are two tiny tiny tiny
little magnets don't know if you see
that yeah yeah there's a big one in the
middle of those tiny little ones drop
inside it canals and they're all bound
the idea drum inside yet and it uses a
lot my thoughts yeah it's a bit ringing
it uses induction to vibrate them
against it yet oh and you can you can
who can hope to take an audio feed so
what was happening as I was walking
along the camera was picking up their
faces sending the feed to the computer
the computer was recognizing their face
and then it was speaking in my ears
who the were in which department were in
so without even knowing them and you who
the work does that make sense
[ __ ] hell Tom took me two mates to
blown my mind you've scraped the website
for all of the different employees then
you've linked that to a camera in your
hat and you've put tiny little magnets
to read so I'm going to guess the reason
for the magnets is that a typical
earpiece would be too conspicuous yeah
[Music]
well I'm glad that you've got your ear
but I mean that's sort of the
sophistication if that's really
terrifying and the other thing as well
as a theme the implication is that if
you're doing it as a white hack that
white hat then the black hat hackers or
people that are doing this for corporate
espionage and stuff like that like if
you're I don't know the the top boffins
and Apple let's say and you're designing
the new iPhone and Samsung or wow it's
how could that say well way the Chinese
are always up to something in technology
at the moment and everyone's worried
about that and they can put all of these
different bits of technology in the
meeting room and they know all the
different bits and pieces or they put
some sort of keyboard key keystroke
tracker on someone's so they can hack
into the backend of all of the
communication channels and you know
you're you're just you're just a guy
that's doing this if you had the weight
of an entire come
like government behind you what what can
I do then nation-states are on a whole
new level a whole new level
have you heard of Stuxnet I've heard the
name I don't know why what is it
Stuxnet without putting too much
technical detail it was a virus studied
infected a large volume of computers
across the globe in it took Symantec
several weeks to work out what this
famous was normally it takes them about
10 15 minutes to see oh this is a worm
this is this this is how it works this
is how it propagates but Stuxnet they
didn't know what it was for a long time
it had bits of cord that they didn't
know what it was and how it worked and
it was infecting computers on a level
that they've never seen before
it was infecting USB sticks removable
media transferring it everywhere and it
wasn't doing anything yeah they just
sitting there being been very
intimidating and it turned out it was
looking for one system and that system
was the Iranian nuclear enrichment
program and this bug was so
sophisticated it had four zero dears in
it in a zero day is worth about a
million dollars it's like a halt an
unknown halt in an operating system or
service and it's that findeth which
point at the nation-state and what he'd
done when it found this power plant all
this unknown cord was to control the
industrial controllers of the factory so
what it done isn't recorded that's
covertly of the factory for about 30
days it then disabled the safety
mechanisms because they were all through
a computer and then even replayed the
good stats so if you know like in films
where the the capturing a footage and
then the loop that [ __ ] trying to
commit a crime honestly say TV camera
well this was doing it on doing it on a
nuclear enrichment system so once it was
playing back the good stats it started
speeding up and slowing down all the
centrifuges until I exploded and it blew
up thousands of centrifuges physically
explosions actually happened this
actually may be wrong wow I'm not mad
oh hey with news and stuff like that so
I very well might have missed it but
that is terrifying and obviously the
implications are that could be for
pretty much you know if they can get
into the Iranian nuclear enrichment
plant like what what really is left
after that what's got more security than
that well it wasn't even connected to
the internet okay right so it's not yeah
it was a gap so that's why they were in
fact in removable media so one person
plug that stick into that computer and
that system was doomed
absolutely doomed I mean this there's
amazing things which happen all of the
time this device that are floated before
the little radio transceiver and there
was a guy called Barnaby Jack who was a
New Zealand based ethical hacker he was
the guy who used to hack bank machines
and he could tell you something it was
for him in the bank machine would put
jackpot on the screen and start that's
money yeah he was a showman and absolute
sherman super genius and he discovered
that peacemakers and morphine pumps were
and insulin pumps a lot of them not all
of them were susceptible to an SDR
attack so he potentially could
defibrillate the person by pressing in
there on his keyboard from about a
hundred yards away and he approached the
big company and companies and said look
you know this is a major security flaw
and they said were not interested so he
was going to sort of tell everyone how
it was done had a big convention and
unfortunately died before the convention
was the suspicious death
who knows why he dies he died died of a
drug overdose of the speedball of drugs
two days before his big convention so
I'm led to believe one of them Wow and
he was it it's a young guy he wasn't
like because a young guy he was famous
he had an amazing career beautiful
family you know ya know I mean cause
it's weird isn't it like when we talk
about all of this stuff it's it's
fascinating and really but I love
learning about it and it's really
interesting but there's just when you
finish laughing about whatever the point
is and you remember if this gets into
the hands of the wrong people if this is
used on the wrong sort of facility it's
the implications are really scary on
they mean or do they mean or talk about
it yeah this is is in the hands of the
wrong people
yeah the havok now they use it now and
what gets me is the media attended demon
alleys hackers yeah we're told like they
tell everyone that we are the bad guys
with the hackers are the good guys the
cyber criminals are the bad guys
they're the ones who if you how can I
put it isn't another right okay think of
Gordon Ramsay Jeffrey Dahmer yeah yeah
so Gordon Ramsay will use a knife to
cook you a meal and it'll be beautiful
Jeffrey Dahmer would use a knife to kill
you any year yep yeah that knife is
hacking does that make sense yes and
then Gordon Ramsay's the hacker and
Jeffrey Dahmer's the cyber criminals and
that's the best way you saw the text
Liana civilians will understand there is
a battle between good and evil same same
tool but different direction absolutely
absolutely
okay so going on to we touched on it
earlier on the the stuff to do with
nation-state and things like that just
how much power and resources do you
think countries are throwing into this
both on the defense
on the offense side obviously that I've
listened to I don't know how much you
listen to Joe Rogan but he he often has
a couple of guys on from the CIA in the
FBI who are now retired and they talk
about our way and Samsung TVs being
installed with these particular chips
and the backdoors and the Chinese having
government officials working inside of
every big company and all this sort of
stuff all the time
absolutely absolutely to me you've got
to understand that deer are now is worth
more than oil yeah so the data about
people big data to train machine
learning algorithms etc etc it's worth
more than also it's it's a very very
valuable resource that people want and
so they're gonna put a lot of money in a
secure amount and we're going to put a
lot of money in a defendant now I'm
genuinely proud of living in England and
in Britain because we have some of the
best security professionals in the world
genuinely that I am absolutely true
absolutely true they don't make a big
thing about it and that's what's great
about yeah you've got some amazing
amazing people absolutely unbelievable
people protecting us now and it
genuinely does blow my mind but you have
a lot of threat actors as well so you've
got China
you've got Russia you've got North Korea
you've got all the states that wouldn't
necessarily get on with us politically
and you have to understand that for the
price of one fighter plane you can hire
200 hackers to get me point so
information warfare is going to be the
future of war it's as simple as that if
you don't spend the money you're not
going to be able to defend against it
and you need to spend a lot to be able
to defend effectively I can't quantify
that because I don't know enough about
it but I know that you have to spend
some money and especially invest in
education and in teaching people and
making people aware you've got to
remember that all the meddling in the
elections in the US and everything was
all all the email leaks it was all based
upon a phishing campaign which was a
social engineering attack so you know it
was once said that hackers used
technology but the professionals hack
the person yeah so you know we've just
got it
everybody needs to do the bit in my
opinion we're entering into an
Information Age
we all have mini supercomputers attached
or something hip you know for it but
Google things like you know what you
don't know the answer you just google it
straight away and you know the answer
it's there we are now integrating more
and more and more with technology and if
we don't protect that and if we don't
know ourselves you know we're gonna be
backfist does this need to happen a
state level or the things that an
individual level which we all should be
doing as well apart from 12-string
passwords and not using the password
password one I think I think governments
do have a responsibility to protect us
and that's what we are elected for and
so far I think the UK of done a
fantastic job you know there is going to
be attacks all the time but how many
they stop and how many they defend
against it you know we will never know
but they are doing their bit but I think
common sense is a big thing you know
don't just have super complex passwords
but just don't share them between all
sorts of different platforms because if
I get your Linkedin there's a very good
chance he emails gonna have the same
password is your LinkedIn assault and
similar so I'm good at arguing email
because I'm not going to recover all the
passwords the email from all the other
accounts does that make sense
remember a few things whatever you put
on the internet will always remain on
the Internet
there's no getting rid of it it's going
to be there to respite that it's
captured if you're using IOT devices or
internet with things like CCTV cameras
and things like that buy them from
reputable places you know do your
homework if you're buying a camera from
China that's 20 quid in the same one
from a British manufacturer whatever us
150 quid there's a reason why do you
know what I mean that reason tends to be
the fact that the rubbish the crap they
don't protect you in fact the very
devices that we use to protect those so
things work to the flavor of the
cybercriminals one of my demonstrations
is something called Google docking the
end of Google talking know take it
through really really simple technique
it's using advanced search operate as in
Google to look for misconfigured systems
now anybody can do it without any
technical capabilities whatsoever they
just need to know where the look I'm not
going to tell you a lot but it's called
it's called Google hacking if you're
interested been looking and you can put
in a string and you can explore create
brought in cameras or come us when I say
brought and I mean cameras that aren't
set up correctly now with one line of
court I can find 500 web cameras that I
can log into some of them are CCTV
cameras so you know it's it's really
scary stuff it's scary stuff and some of
the listeners will know I had Roger
McNamee who was one of the early
investors in Facebook personal advisor
to Mark Zuckerberg he was that the guy
that got Sheryl Sandberg on board then
just before that I spoke to Professor
David Carroll who was the man the
professor from the great hack on Netflix
spoke to both of those guys within a
couple of days of each other
and it definitely just feel at the
moment like everything is gathering pace
and the the online attacks or the online
threats just they're increasing in their
magnitude across all all platforms as
far as I see so it's
it's not just that you have this sort of
below the line underground black hat
hacker things that are going on but also
even the data which were willingly
giving away is being manipulated in more
more and more sophisticated ways and you
know it really is it's getting it's
getting more serious isn't it
it absolutely is all these apps like the
ten fierce up and the ten year puberty
challenge teddy and puberty challenge
was used to capture data of people ten
years ago it now so they can build a
machine learning model that machine
learning model potentially could be used
for face up to predict better aging of
people and that's why you take
photograph yourself amid ages here
because it's all based on a dataset yeah
so it's it's scary stuff I'm just
sending you a little link that I've just
pulled up on a Google Doc okay and this
is actually a misconfigured CCTV camera
on a university in America okay so you
just done it you've just done a life
hack there and now I've clicked on this
link I won't say where it is and now and
now I can i wow I can actually pan left
and right until the consuming themself
this camera up and down I can see people
walking around Tom this is [ __ ]
terrifying mate I can see this student
walking towards class he's got a hoodie
on he's got his hands in the hoodie and
there's some people some guys sat down
having a a Starbucks just on this thing
here and I can zoom myself back so I can
have a little bit wider of a look
[Laughter]
anybody can do without any coding skills
without anything it's just creative
google searching and a while back the
somebody using google talking found all
of the firmware and the software for all
of the Boeing planes I believe our
backyard including the new 7/7
and the you know the fund all of the
sauce board for the plane so it law it
doesn't take much to master it's a very
very powerful little tool it is and I
suppose the thing as well is that as the
effectiveness and the power of the
systems that were using increase the
concern with someone do it using that
for a nefarious purpose is it goes up in
line with that right so Navarre rava
can't there's an unbelievable podcast
that I'll send to you once we're done
actually it's Rob Reid from the after on
podcast with Navarre and I'll put it in
the show notes below for anyone who
wants to listen as well they'll have
heard me mention it before basically
talks about all of the different ways
that they're concerned about the future
all the different ways that the world
could end as far as they were concerned
they go through sin bio the synthetic
biology stuff which they're [ __ ]
terrified about that includes
nanotechnology that's what's really
worrying through some some stuff to do
with being able to deploy drones with
tiny amounts of c-4 in them out at the
back of a plane and then those drones
are attached to facial recognition
software and as opposed to dropping a
big nuclear bomb on a on a city whereby
it would make the city uninhabitable for
a few years they could just drop twenty
thousand of these little drones out
these drones would detect all of the
people all of the men or all of the
black men or all of the white women or
all of the the people that voted one
particular way facial recognition tiny
little penny sized amount of plastic
explosive the safest people in all of
the UK but yet they're talking about all
of this stuff and one of the things
that's really interesting it kind of
rounds this discussion off nicely I
guess with regards to some
some of the importance of what we're
talking about with regards to data
security at the moment what they say is
that in the past the most damage that
anybody could have done to 300 years ago
the most damage anybody could have done
would have been shot one person once out
of a musket and then that would have
been it that was really the peak of what
we could do maybe hit someone with a
cannonball but that was fairly fairly
inaccurate and as technology grows and
as these weapons and as the the
delegation and the how would you put it
the ability for people to understand how
to do destructive things becomes more
and more well understood and then more
and more well distributed it means that
it won't be long before someone will be
able to already do it 3d printing guns
there we go a perfect example you've got
technology with some coding that's come
together you can 3d print a gun how long
before you can 3d print a bomb of some
kind or you know all of these things I
suppose what that means is we need to be
even more security conscious because the
stakes of getting it wrong increasingly
get worse and worse
absolutely I mean that runs a little
ugly you know as things are progressing
we're going to be faced with lots of new
challenges and if we don't adapt as a
race we're going to end up destroying
ourselves I mean now you know it's
possible very unlikely but it's possible
for a rogue hacker to shut down the
power plant or to do a run somewhere
attack on a on a water-treatment factory
and and filled the water with loads of
chlorine or you know there's so many
different things you can do that are
damaging with technology now and if we
don't stay one step ahead of it if we
don't have a good educational system and
and people to inspire young minds and to
get them involved in being a white hat
in an ethical hacker you know we're
gonna be in a world of hurt we're
genuinely are are you guys I'm going to
guess the answers yes but you guys will
be paid fairly well for your services it
will be a specialized and small group of
people who have skills up to the
standard that are required well the
average we
qualified penetration tester with a bit
of experience is between 65 and 120
thousand pound yet and there is going to
be a 1.8 million job deficit within the
next three years so nobody will have the
skill set to do that
my suggestion would be if you want me
career change do what add on you know
quit your minimum-wage job but like
yourself in the university and smush it
the best you possibly can drop in
headfirst take on every opportunity do
the best you possibly can and change
your life because you can do it Tom what
unbelievable way to end the podcast
thank you so much for coming on man if
if anyone who is listening wants to
learn a little bit more
are there any blogs that you like or if
you've got anything online I'm you on
Twitter for some reason I was I thought
that you might say that I'm paranoid
only got a phone about a month ago yeah
what I would suggest is if you want to
learn more get yourself on hack the box
it is a website designed to teach
hacking and you can legally hack their
networks and allow you to do it and have
live different captioned flight
challenges things like that awesome
you've got over the way our wargames
have a go of that loon Kali Linux the
best you can and if you're a student or
you've got access to an academic email
get yourself on massive labs which was
set up in conjunction with our saw the
GCHQ technical soccer departments of the
government and they have sort of labs
that you can learn on there as well play
around play around in these safe
environments where you can do a little
bit of a key and see if you're any good
and then maybe flog your skills for a
hundred and twenty grand a year don't
think that we could have done a better
recruitment video if we tried links to
everything that we've spoken about today
Navarre Rob account on Rob reads after
on links to hack the box over the wire
and some of the other bits and pieces
we've gone through will be in the show
notes below as
always if you enjoyed this please don't
forget to give us a like and hit
subscribe it really does make me happy
Tom man thank you so much I'm really
excited to see what happens next I guess
we'll have to wait a couple of years
until the non-disclosure agreement
probably frees up and you can actually
talk about it but yeah what an awesome
day thank you so much fun fantastic
thank you
[Music]
you